build it dry quiet Vsauce Kevin here
were some of the coolest creations from
extraordinary people
this is PDP building sebastian hoover
Robert Pola and Johannes temper Naugle
built an interactive framework that
transforms a user and the surroundings
into a system of particles with audio by
berlin-based clink Clank lungs the body
movements trigger sounds as well as
visuals and the motion tracking is done
with Xbox Kinect Carol Milne knits with
glass she created a technique of
knitting strands of wax together and
then encases the sculpture in refractory
mold material into which she pours
molten glass and she wishes for her work
to be viewed as a metaphor for social
structure as individual strands are weak
and brittle on their own but deceptively
strong Lynn bound together Zollner
electronic AG has built a giant robot
dragon it's the current record holder
for the world's largest walking robot
measuring in at 51 feet long 40 feet
wide and 26 feet 10 inches high it can
walk breathe fire and is controlled by a
remote and has been displayed at fairs
and plays all around Germany draw
Martine fáil brings cloud shapes to life
he takes pictures of suggestively shaped
clouds and illustrates them with the
first thing that comes to mind as a
child he was told that clouds shapes
were created by balloon twisting clowns
that live in the sky and this project is
an exploration of that memory Eric
Stanley uses lasers to cut intricate
designs into hundreds of sheets of paper
each piece takes months of drawing and
planning and his overarching goal has
been to recreate the majesty and scale
of Gothic and Islamic architecture and
then bring it into a considerably
smaller space and now for the art of
Scott lists field featuring an astronaut
that explores pop culture and the
present
Mary doodles combines her love of
drawing with her passion for improv on
her YouTube show titled what will I draw
she turned scribbles into fully realized
works of art such as an assassin a swamp
witch or a dying
dragon playing story also uses period
authentic replicas of age-old Belarusian
instruments to accurately recreate
medieval music and here's their version
of Metallica's one
chemical legs baikal throughs features
an industrial vibe combined with sounds
from 80s videogames and here he is
showing off is hands-on sense skills at
Room 205
finally Mangusta came a pegas bi-lo
sponse test features a human pinata and
was directed by barcelona-based
production company canada
inspiration also comes from you Vsauce
creative fan showcase first up is make
acid with power bomb let's go
David Loyola makes paper cut desk
ornaments using an exacto knife paper
wood glass and plenty of patience Donnie
Phillips laser cuts vinyl records into
portraits of rock stars including David
Bowie Morrissey and Tom Waits the metro
created this glowing animation for a
song by Jacque ooh
Phoenix create custom snapback hats with
handmade bills based in Los Angeles they
have an Etsy shop where they sell
they're one of the kind hats odd Arnie
roll made a virtual reality Lego helmet
using a smartphone with a 3d app and
some inexpensive lenses Shin Cheng Xu
made a gesture controlled robotic arm
and now the graphic design of Kriss
Halderman
submit your bidipis to be DP at Vsauce
dot-com or share them with everyone on
Twitter with hashtag PDP and as always
thanks for watching
whoa
Oh